Hello, everyone.
I'm Daniela Rus,
and I make robots.
I'm a robotics researcher
at MIT's Computer Science
and Artificial Intelligence
Laboratory, or CSAIL, and also
the director of CSAIL.
And today I will be
moderating this panel
on the future of computing.
So in this panel, we
hope to explore with you
some of our latest
insights and the challenges
that our researchers
are tackling
in the field of computing.
We also will discuss what the
future of the digital landscape
might look like and how
computer science research will
make a difference in
how we live, we work,
and we play in the future.
I will tell you more about
CSAIL in just a minute.
First, I would like to
introduce our panelists.
Tim Berners-Lee probably
needs no introduction,
but he invented the world
wide web 25 years ago in 1989
when he was a researcher at
CERN, which is the European
Particle Physics Laboratory.
And today Tim is a crusader
for a world wide web that
is of even greater
benefit to humanity
to easy access to information
and through providing
more transparency on
how governments operate.
Andrew Lo was named
by Time Magazine
one of the most
influential people
of the year for his innovative
approach to financial markets.
And Lo is an
economist by training.
He is a faculty member at MIT
Sloan School of Management.
He directs the laboratory
for financial engineering,
and he's also principle
investigator at CSAIL.
And Russ Tedrake
can make robots that
fly like birds,
run like ostriches,
and these days, he's directing
his innovative approaches
to creating robots that can
assist in search and rescue.
Russ finds his
inspiration in nature,
and today he will
tell you about what
we might expect from the field
of robotics and from robots
into the future.
So I will share with
you just a few words
about CSAIL, the organization
we all belong to,
then we will hear
from the panelists.
And at the end of
their brief speeches,
we will open the floor
for general questions.
So first of about CSAIL.
We have over 100
senior researchers.
That means faculty and
principle investigators.
And we have over 500 students.
That means postdocs,
graduate students,
and undergraduate researchers.
And we are the largest
interdisciplinary research
laboratory at MIT.
We were founded 50 years
ago as Project Math,
and since then,
our laboratory has
played a very important role in
the technological revolution,
starting with the early days
of time-sharing computers
to the birth of data encryption.
Our objective is to
teach our students
to become world-class computer
scientists, to be big thinkers,
and to become
constructive innovators,
that we take the field of
computing to the next level
and also take on
some of the world's
most pressing challenges.
Our researchers include
robotic researchers like myself
as well as experts in
all fields of computing--
security, mobile,
wireless, robotics,
artificial intelligence,
databases, theory.
You name it, we have
experts in the field.
And because of this
diverse range of interests,
we are very excited
and very well equipped
to take on interdisciplinary
challenges.
And all together,
we imagined a world
where computing can turn the
world into a better place.
We imagine a world
where physicians
can use the most advanced
knowledge on genomics
to engineer better treatments
that are individualized
for patients.
We imagine a world where
data can help us all
make better decisions
by predicting
the consequences
of our decisions
and where the most recent
advances in encryption
research, for example,
and differential privacy
and homomorphic
encryption put people
in charge of their own data.
We also imagine a
world where robots
will be as common as
smartphones and cars
and where robots
can do everything,
from helping with search
and rescue activities
to folding your laundry,
which is my least
favorite chore at home.
So we really believe
that computing
has a lot to offer in
the way our world will
be shaping the future.
And with this, I would
like to stop and turn it
over to Tim Berners-Lee,
who will talk to us
about the web we want.
Tim?
Thanks.
So it's great to be here.
Thank you for coming.
If you have a--
put your hand up in the seat
next you, if you have a seat?
So the awesome seats over
here, if you need them.
So thank you all for coming.
Great to be here.
Thank you back at
South by Southwest.
It's 25 years ago
that I originally
wrote a memo proposing the
world wide web project.
And so-- I want to just check
all of the other [INAUDIBLE]..
So we've got three the
world wide web project
I wrote a memo about.
That was 25 years ago.
I published a memo, which
has got these scribblings
on the front about
reorganizing information.
And for the first
three years, it
was actually quite difficult
to persuade everybody
that it would be a good idea.
It wouldn't be too complicated,
and that they should give out
their own proprietary
system to open it up,
the psychological
thing of getting
open about putting some
of the things on the web.
But there were
people who got it.
And just like now when you look
around, South by Southwest,
you see a lot of people
with a twinkle in their eye
because they get the idea of
how the world means everything
in the media.
25 years, I want to ask
what's the web we want.
So step back very easy for us
to use the web every moment.
It's only when you're
under the Mubarak regime
in Egypt turns the web off or
other things happen on the web
that you realize that
actually, it's not just
like the air we breathe.
You actually have to
step back and think
about what is behind it and
think about whether it's always
going to be there and
think about the properties
that it can.
But it got us this far now we're
going to continue to happen.
There are many threats
to rights from the web.
Recently people
have started to talk
about human rights on the web.
Many human rights were
established like the pre web
builders work, from
what you call and you
talk about the
Magna Carta in 1215,
and we talk about the
US Bill of Rights.
If you're brought
up in South Africa,
then you're probably very
proud of your new constitution.
It's put together with a
very good bill of rights,
but, hopefully, to the
right, none of them
mention the internet.
And to some extent,
we can just demand
those rights we have shouldn't
exist on the internet.
But in fact, it turns out
that when you go from there,
then it turns out that
some of the things that you
wanted like the ability
to connect to anyone--
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, but that's not really.
That needs to be called
out because somebody
could tell you, yes, we're
giving you connectivity.
You couldn't get these people,
connect to our partners
through our partner
or companies.
[INAUDIBLE] and say,
oh, I want to be
able to connect to any
new upstart company.
I don't want to
just watch movies,
I want to watch
movies with anybody
who has started making a little
startup, making a film company,
and so on.
There are a number
of countries who
are putting internet
regulation legislation, ideas
about the internet
being a right,
make sure it's something
obviously the country
needs you.
There are various declarations
people got out there,
the Declaration of
Internet Freedom is one.
You can check those out.
You can sign them, and share
with the people somebody
you might know,
somebody that might
be hanging around the South
by Southwest who've signed
that declaration of freedom.
So what do we mean when we talk
about rights on the internet?
Well, of course, we're talking
about those thieves or things
like expressions,
free expressions.
That means I don't
want to be censored.
I will need to be able
to get to what I want.
And also, as a person I
need to put myself out
there so that anybody else
can see it in any country.
The web blew up as a
non-national thing.
At this point, it's an
international thing.
International sounds like
nations getting together.
No.
Web grew up
irrelevant of nations.
It's ended up, the
internet was connected up,
and the time and the server
when you connect the web browser
to the web server, they don't
care about national boundaries.
That has had some really
sweet side effects in a way,
but its international
community has grown up.
Censorship blocks
really messes that up.
It doesn't happen
in every country.
Happens in different areas.
We have to keep track
of that in the future,
but very important to be
aware where it's happening.
Access.
Just ability to access the web.
So about now, the
number of people
who got internet, could
access the web technically
is around 40%.
So that is great for the 40%.
And the web internet is becoming
more and more powerful in lots
of ways, every moment.
And this component is
more and more cool,
and it's more and more
empowering for people
to do their own medicine,
have their own [INAUDIBLE]
later, in another session
you'll be excited about.
All these new things
you've done that
make it more and more
powerful and makes
the gap between the
40% that do have
and the 60% that don't
have it even bigger.
Obviously, for people who don't,
many things get in the way.
Sometimes it's poverty,
sometimes it's illiteracy.
Some obviously, are
grouped for mobile.
In Saharan Africa, in developing
countries, in general,
it's mobile, the mobile
web, which is taking over.
Critical things are the
cost of the gadget that
can do web and the
cost of the beta plans,
not necessarily broadband,
but some sort of broadband,
something that will let me do
email, be part of the browsing
the websites, see how they
do information society
and recreate it myself.
I want our people just not just
to go and see the extent of we
put together by a videographer,
then get on, make it themselves
in their own language so
you see more and more stuff
in foreign language.
So one of the properties of
the web is that it's open.
That means lots the things.
Open means lots of things.
Teach people part how
to build some standards.
Obviously, many of
you may have worked
on building web standards
following the latest
versions of HTML5, the APIs.
And so keeping those open,
keeping it royalty free.
A really crucial
point, the place
I worked for in
Switzerland, CERN,
that physics lab
are taking months.
We persuade them
to actually provide
a document, because
you know what,
CERN is not going to charge
a lot for the web technology.
That was a really
crucial point of uptake.
Since then, it was the point
in the consortium's history
where we realized we had to
get all consortium members who
are involved in what we do.
They also, when we've
come to this fact,
we aren't going to try to
get royalties for people
who have implemented them.
That's the main part of it.
Now, the corporate part
of being a open support
is the neutrality of media.
Censorship is when it's block.
Net neutrality, it's not
just not being blocked
or parliament neutrality,
many challenges,
but you don't mess with it.
The ISPs, for example,
the famous one in Holland
that slowed down Skype
because they noticed
the Skype was starting to eat
into their telephone revenue,
created that.
Turned that around
pretty quickly.
In just legislation,
you can't do that.
In America, the convention is
that internet service providers
provide you with connecting
to everyone you want,
and they don't slow
down packets go
into their commercial
enemies, but they're always
under such tremendous
commercial pressure
to do so because they can
make such a mint if they
can actually get a stranglehold
on you as a consumer
and just connect to
who you connect to.
So this is the Central
American illustrating
the picture of the
happy ion couple
underneath all the people
or all the demons trying
to get up the workings of these
net and use it, some of you
are on there.
So many times it's
important, many think,
I think it's important
for the commercial world,
for an open market,
of course, it's
important for the
marketers, it's important
that you can go to any
physical site you like.
It's also important for
innovation, the fact
that you can build a new website
and very quickly one person
providing the program, two
people promote this program.
They can send their
package through the cloud
or the internet.
By the way, we're
using the cloud diagram
for the internet on before the
cloud became proudly into our--
So why you care?
Because you don't
care what's inside it.
You can write a program,
she can write program,
they can communicate, and a new
innovative protocol is born.
New innovative system
is running over the web,
a new social media is spreading
across the web, for example.
That's really important
for innovation,
so that's why see that
happen in the next 25 years.
All this, of course, thank
you all for coming here.
We know you had also, to go
where you had streaming live,
and the obvious moment,
this is last year,
there's been a lot
of focus on privacy.
It's a shame that it
took us some revelations
to get us all thinking
about the internet.
Obviously, we have to
think about to what extent
we give the agencies that's
supposed to protect us,
the ability to sample the
internet, spy on the internet,
how I think the really
interesting question is
how we build systems that
will hold them accountable.
Checks and balances traditional
in the Madisonian government.
Checks and balance is equally
built like they've never
been built before.
We need very strong agencies
accountable to the public who
have the power to go in and
investigate the investigators,
and we don't know how
to build that yet.
When it doesn't happen,
it's really important
that we can protest.
We've got our website
can go as Wiki--
actually, went
back, not the other.
So that was when
Wikipedia went back
is when the SOPA legislation
was going to go through.
Also, people went
out into the streets
protesting SOPA in the US,
protesting ACTA in Europe.
ACTA was an agreement
which was going
to give too much power
to copyright holders
and take away freedoms
from individuals.
So this sort of stuff
is important to be
able to do that.
There are lots the
things you have
to be able to protest
about, lots of things
when actually
individual voices have
to be added up so that this
thing is kept open and free.
Those of you who
were here last year,
we were talking about
Aaron Swartz's life
and how he was a huge
part of software so far.
Let's keep doing, in
his memory keep doing
the things what would Aaron do.
So those are some of the
things which I think.
Now, back on my
agenda for the web
we want, so there is a web we
want node called Web at 25.
Well, web 25 that's
going to be live.
On the top of March, which is
another lecture of the web.
I want you all to think
about what sort of world web
you want.
I want you to not
just think about it.
I want you when
necessary to take action.
Make sure.
I have faith that by
the end of the year,
we know what legislation
is properly enacted,
in which countries.
In all of your countries,
what sort of pressure
is going to be put on
the companies necessary.
What sort of spirit do
we want behind the web
that we're going to have
for the next 25 years.
Thank you very
much for your time.
So next, I would
like to turn it over
to Andrew Lo, who will talk to
us about big data, big brother,
and the financial crisis.
Andrew.
Thank you.
Also, while we get
the slides set up,
I want to start by
thanking Daniela
Rus and my other
colleagues at CSAIL
and the organizers
of South by Southwest
for inviting me to participate
in this great panel.
I have to admit that as
a financial economist,
I feel a little bit out
of water and intimidated
because if you look at the
composition of the panel,
we've got two of the leading
roboticists of our generation
and the inventor of
the internet and me.
So who ordered that?
But when I told a
friend of mine that I
was coming to South by
Southwest to be on this panel,
he was very jealous and
said, why are you going?
Isn't South by Southwest all
about disruptive innovation?
And I have to say
that absolutely,
and financial
economists belong here
because at least the
first pact we've got down.
Finance has been
incredibly disruptive.
And so what I want to talk about
is, what do we do about it.
How do we deal
with the challenges
of a financial crisis,
and particularly
big data and the privacy
issues that Tim mentioned.
So I'd like to start by
talking a bit about what
we know of the economy.
And it turns out that
there's actually quite a lot
that we know if we actually
take a look at the data
that we have.
I can break this up.
Over the course of the
last several years,
the economy has been
going up and down,
but over the last few months, it
looks like things are actually
looking pretty good.
So for example, if you take a
look at recent announcements
by the Bureau of
Economic Analysis--
I'll actually bring up the
slides in just a minute.
[INAUDIBLE]
There we go.
Yeah, great.
So what do we know
about the economy?
Well, as I mentioned,
we've got a lot
of data coming in, so we know
that inflation is about 1/10
of a percent; unemployment,
6.6%; GDP growth, 2.4%;
non-farm payroll, 113,000;
housing spark, 180,000.
The fed balance sheet
is $2.6 trillion.
All of these data tell us
where we are in the economy,
that basically things
are getting better,
but we've still
got a ways to go.
However, there is a
huge part of the economy
that we actually
don't know much about,
for example, hedge funds
and the shadow banking
system that were central in
creating the financial crisis.
What do we know about that?
Well, let me show you
the data that we've
collected about hedge funds
and the shadow banking sector.
This is what we know about it--
nothing.
And the reason we don't
know anything about it
is because there is actually
no legal requirements
for hedge funds or the
shadow banks to report.
They're not even actually under
any regulatory jurisdiction.
And so the old adage
goes, you can't
manage what you don't measure,
applies to this sector.
And clearly, we
want to understand
what these data are telling us
about that part of the system.
But at the same time, a lot of
these financial institutions
have argued, well,
we're developing
proprietary trading
strategies and investments
for our shareholders.
And if you believe in
private enterprise,
you don't want to
force us to disclose.
After all, you don't
disclose Coca-Cola's formula,
you want to give
people an incentive
to develop new innovations.
So the question is,
is there some kind
of a compromise between
privacy and total transparency?
And it's pretty clear that
there are certain things that
have to be kept private.
We don't want
total transparency.
The answer is, yes, there's
actually a compromise,
and it has to do with
a new technology,
not so new to computer
science literature,
but new in its
applications to finance.
And the technology is known as
secure multi-party computation.
Let me tell you what it
is with a simple example.
I've always wondered what
the socioeconomic statuses
of participants at
South by Southwest.
So one of the things
I'd like to know
is what the average salary
is of people in this room.
So let me start
by asking, anybody
you want to tell me what
their average salary is so we
can start computing an average?
Not so much.
Well, we obviously
acknowledge that salaries
are a quite confidential thing.
So let me tell you what
my annual salary is
so we can start
trying to compute
the average in this room.
But I'm not going to tell you
what my salary is by itself.
What I'm going to
do is to tell you
what my annual salary is
plus a random number that I
choose and add to my salary.
So my salary plus the
random number is $15.
So hopefully, I added a
negative number to my salary.
So I'm happy to share
that with you, $15.
And I'm going to give that
number to somebody else
in the audience, say, Alice.
And I'm going to ask Alice
to take that number, $15,
and add to that her salary
plus her random number
that only she knows
and she chooses.
And so Alice does that, and
the sum is maybe $37,000.
And Alice takes that
number and gives it
to somebody else who adds
his number and his salary
and passes it along
to somebody else
and to somebody
else and somebody
else until the last person in
the room, Bob, gets the number.
And Bob adds to it his
salary and his random number.
And at that point, the number
turns out to be $15 billion,
and Bob gives it back to me.
I take that number, $15 billion,
and I subtract from that
my random number.
I give it to Alice.
She subtracts her random number.
She passes it and gives
it to the next person who
subtracts her random number and
so on and so forth until Bob
subtract his random number.
And at that point, when Bob
subtracts his random number,
what Bob has is the sum of
everybody's salary, which,
when you divide by the
total number of people
in the room, which everybody can
see, and is public information,
yields the average salary
of everybody in the room.
Nowhere did anybody have to
reveal his or her salary,
but at the end of the day,
we actually have the average.
Now, of course, this algorithm
is a pretty simple one
in the sense that if I
got together with Alice,
I could actually
cheat and figure out
what Bob's salary
is, but there are
more sophisticated
algorithms that
allow no cheating to go on
and yet permit us to calculate
numbers like average salaries
or average loan portfolios
or average concentration
indexes of credit default swaps,
things that will tell us what
the systemic exposures are
for the aggregate economy
without jeopardizing privacy.
So let me conclude
by pointing out
that with the right technology,
transparency and privacy can
both be achieved.
You don't have to give
it up as long as you
have the wherewithal
and the right tools
to be able to deal with
these kind of challenges.
Thank you.
Thank you, Andrew.
Next, I'll turn it over
to Russ Tedrake, who
will tell us why the
robots are coming here,
and how they're coming here.
Yeah.
Hi there.
So it's sort of a cheesy
title, The Robot Are Coming.
I had to think a
lot about whether I
was going to use
the title, but I
feel like there's never been a
time before where I would have
felt right using the
title, and there may never
be a time again
where I'll feel right
using such a cheesy title.
But let me tell you why.
Robots are trending
in such a way
right now, just in
a massive proportion
that this felt like the one
time where I could get away
maybe using the title.
And maybe it's not
even their coming,
but they're actually here.
And I want to make sure you guys
know the extent to which they
are trending.
And it happened with
a lot of progress
in academia and industry.
And then it got
quickly spurred on
by this relatively
massive investment
first by the government.
So there's a National
Robotics Initiative
that happened three years
ago now where the robotics
community got together,
formed a robotics caucus,
and the Congress made
robotics a national agenda
and produced research money for
academic research in robotics.
There's another big huge
another $80 million or so
coming from DARPA that
was injected into building
robotic hardware in the US.
So you're just seeing
many, many more robots
moving around, walking
around in the United States.
It's a worldwide phenomenon.
All over, the European Union has
massive funding for robotics.
Japan and Korea have
been leaders in robotics,
even at MIT where
we've been spending
our precious few junior
faculty slots filling in
with roboticists because we
know that robotics is hot.
It's hot now.
Google just shocked
the world in December
saying that they purchased eight
of the big robotics companies
in the last six months.
So why did all this happen?
Why is it all so much energy?
Because in the last five or
six years, robots got awesome.
You must have seen
this before, right?
So this Wild Katherine
Boston Dynamics.
This is UADs that are flying
around individually doing
amazing things, but
collectively doing amazing swarm
computations that scale.
That's at UPenn.
This is an airplane.
Airplanes don't normally
land on a perch.
This airplane would
developed at CSAIL.
It can stall its wings
and like a bird and land
on a perch like a bird.
Maybe it will land
on power lines
to triple charge its
batteries then keep flying.
And in fact, it's so
robust that now we
have Joe just throwing
airplanes at wires all day long.
Manipulation
capabilities of robots,
the hardware technology
that we've got now,
this is from Germany.
This just showcases the
robotic arm technology
that is mature, the
robotic hand technology
able to do relatively advanced
manipulation paths with flair.
The sensing
capabilities of robotics
has been just
phenomenal progress.
This is a connect sensor
that one of John Leonard's
colleagues, Tom Whelan, is
walking through his apartment
once with a Microsoft
connect sensor, prime sensor.
And after just a single
traverse of the apartment,
look at the kind of
map he can pull out.
But robots can see now.
They can't necessarily
understand what they're seeing,
but the geometric representation
of the world problem
is on a wave.
Robots can see the environment.
And now robots are going out and
taking all these technologies
and putting them together
and solving hard problems out
in the real world,
but one of the ones
that I've been involved
in the last year
is this project by
DARPA, a competition
by DARPA, where we
had to field robots.
They didn't have to
be humanoid robots,
but used the humanoid robot
that had to go out and handle
a disaster response scenario.
So this is the scene
where they put us
in front of a debris pile.
We had to clear debris
and get through--
to imagine the door at
the end of the debris.
But the point is, we didn't
set this up and pick one video
and put it on YouTube.
This is a challenge that
had to work on game day.
We had one shot
with the real robot.
The robot we some
human operators that
were connected to the robot with
a very degraded network link.
So they were allowed to get
high-level commands where
they couldn't steer and
control the whole robot,
and I'll just show you
a really quick summary
of the kind of things we do.
I set it up, so I didn't
use too much of my time.
But the robot is pretty
amazingly capable.
In fact, this was a good thing
for the bipeds in the world.
We just had this big
competition in December.
Everybody said
that the people who
are bringing bipedal
robots, all the robots
are just going to fall down
an embarrassing themselves.
But in fact, the
robots did very well.
The bipedals did very well.
This guy happens
to be so wide that.
I don't know if you remember
Hans and Franz on Saturday
Night Live.
The only way we can get through
the door was going sideways.
It cost is valuable
time, but that was it.
This is taking up a
drill, turning it on,
and then you got to cut
of shape out of a wall.
And these aren't walls.
These are things that had
to work on competition day,
so picking up a fire hose
and mating it with a spigot,
we can do this in the wild now.
Slowly.
And DARPA put on
this amazing event
where they've actually rented
a NASCAR stadium, the Homestead
Speedway, and we had all the 18
most advanced humanoid robots
in the world.
And each of these could
walk down Pit Crew Lane
and see all these
humanoids and all
the most stressed
out programmers
in the world working on
their robots the day before.
And they put it through
all these competitions.
All right, so it's easy
to say that and then
make you think that
robotics is solved,
but there's lots of
things we can't do yet.
So the robots today were
moving not very gracefully,
very slowly.
We wanted them to
move like ballerinas.
I would be happy if our
Atlas robot, our big humanoid
had the manipulation
capabilities
of a two-year-old or
three-year-old here.
If I have a factory where I have
a perfectly specified object,
maybe I'm OK.
But if I have unknown objects
I haven't seen before,
it's still a very
hard problem for us.
Object recognition,
scene understanding,
high-level decision
making, these
are all technical
problems that we're
going to be tackling
in the next few years.
But there's big
problems with robotics
too, bigger than these one-off
research problems, the thing
that's going to get the robots
out of the YouTube world
and into the real world is
solving problems about robots
being tipped gradually.
They fall down, they break.
It's very depressing when
you work that hard on a robot
and they break.
But there's new
fabrication technologies
out there that, for
instance, Daniela
is working on that are
making soft robots that
will be able to recover from--
this is one of Daniela's videos
of a earthworm
robot that she hits
with a mallet at all times.
And if we can figure out how
to not only build these things,
but control these things to be
as dexterous as the videos I've
been showing you,
that can totally
reshape the robotic landscape.
Robots are too expensive.
We spent millions of dollars
on that humanoid robot you saw.
And if I want to send
them out into the world,
we're going to have to make
them much, much cheaper,
and soft robotics can
help with that too.
They're using too much energy.
The humanoid robot I
showed you actually,
the reason it had a tether was
because it pulls 15 kilowatts
off the wall when
it's standing still.
So if you've seen
the big dog robot,
the big dog has a 15 horsepower
motor, and it's about 1/8
of a horse.
So I guess if you do the math,
it's about 100 times less
efficient than a horse.
We're going to have
to solve that if we
want to get them out there.
We also have to make
it easier for people
to work on robots
out in the field
and give them legislation
to support this community
and foster the environment.
But this is a good time.
This is an amazing
time for you to get
involved if you're thinking
about a robotics startup.
There's never been
a better time where
there's cop sensors out
there, off-the-shelf sensors,
actuators, even robots.
The robotics
community has finally
embraced the open
source movement,
both for hardware and
software, the maker movement
has impacted robotics
in a major way.
You can download plans
for entire humanoids
now and get involved.
We just released the
entire planning and control
infrastructure code base for
that humanoid robot I showed.
If you're interested in
using that, send me an email.
I will help you
build this because I
think this is so important
for robotics to get out there.
You can downline machine shops.
I think if you guys can dream
up new consumer applications
and we can work together,
then we can drive down costs,
and we can solve
really hard problems.
And there's never been
a more important time
for academia to team with
industry and other academics
to bring in the
next wave of robots.
I think we're really entering
an exciting era for robotics.
Thank you, Russ.
Well, I hope you can
see the enthusiasm
that we have for the future
and for what computing can
do to improve our lives and
give us better ways to work,
to play, and to live.
And so please join us
in this enthusiasm,
and please join
us in the Q&A. Let
me start the Q&A session
by asking each one
of our panelists one question.
And I see that there are
microphones in the aisles.
Please join us with
your questions.
So Tim, you created this
really exciting view
for the future of the world
wide web, for the web we want.
What new technologies might be
needed to get to your dream?
Well, so the current state
we're at, web developer, HTML5,
what's different about HTML5
compared to the original web I
started 25 years ago is
that every web page instead,
is completely programmable.
And the power that
we're giving as we
get more APIs, like the
system APIs to the web page
means that you can program
your web page to do anything
the programmer computed with.
And with real-time
communication, WebRTC,
you could get two web pages or
two versions of the same web
page run by different
users talking to each other
without necessarily
going through the server.
So you can build a new
distributed application
using peer-to-peer protocols
across the internet based
on web app technology.
So that is happening right now.
It's going to happen in
browsers like we use [INAUDIBLE]
really exciting.
And I imagine that
will cause people
to build really exciting,
new platforms on top of that.
So that's an example
that we have from web
on top of the
internet, web hoopla,
web app on top of the web and
exciting things on top of that.
Thank you, Tim.
So in your view of the web, you
have articulated the importance
of privacy, and that is actually
a common theme in your dream
and in Andrew's dream.
And so let me ask
you, Andrew, in terms
of this multi-party protocol
you have outlined for us,
is it used today?
In what feels like we
imagined using those ideas?
Well, I mean, parts of it
are certainly used today
because it's based upon ideas
that were pioneered by some
of the early cryptographers,
folks at CSAIL,
like Ron Rubesta, Shapi
Goblosser, Sylvia Tolley,
these are giants in the
field, and they pioneered
a lot of applications.
When you use a credit
card transaction online,
you're using part of these
kind of encryption methods.
Secure multi-party
computation, though where
you're allowing individuals
to encrypt their data
and then share
the encrypted data
to be able to compute with
it, that's really new.
And part of the newness
comes from the fact
that it's only been a
few years ago that we
solved the problem
with so-called fully
homomorphic encryption.
That's a scary-sounding word.
It simply means that you can
encrypt your private data,
then give somebody
that encrypted data,
and they can take that data
and compute certain statistics
as if they had the unencrypted
data, but at no time
can they access the
underlying data.
And you can imagine the
applications are huge.
For example, not just in
financial application,
but health care.
Imagine if we could share
all of our health care
data to figure out what truly
causes cancer or diabetes,
but without having
to disclose details
about our own private
medical condition.
That's an example
where I think it
will transform our society if
we don't get the technology out
there.
So that's really
great, and it was
very exciting to see
in your presentation
the collaboration between
computer scientist and finance.
And I just wonder if you can
elaborate just a little bit
more on this.
Over the past decade and even
before it into the next decade,
how will computer
scientists and economists
come together to solve even
more important problems?
Well, you know more
and more, I think
computer science
is actually getting
involved in a number of
economic transactions.
Actually, part of that is
thanks to Tim Berners-Lee
on the internet.
Of course, e-commerce
now is something
that we all take for granted.
So the idea between computer
science, particularly mechanism
design, option theory, and
how you construct the better
marketplaces for interactions
is really coming to the fore.
So I think that over the
course of the next four years,
we're going to see even more
powerful algorithms that
will ultimately allow
us to do a better
job of allocating scarce
resources across lots
of different needs.
So thank you, Andrew.
So Russ, before you stand up,
I want to ask you a question.
I'm very excited to
about your presentation
because you and I share
the dream of robots coming.
So there has been a lot of
talk about self-driving cars
recently.
Where else are
the robots coming?
Can you comment on this?
I actually think
self-driving cars
is a perfect example of both
where we need legislation
to help so it makes
it easier for people
to do the experiments
they need to do to make
self-driving cars a reality.
I also think that so Google
has got the most visible
self-driving car
product, but all
the major automated factories
have self-driving car products.
But these cars are
driving right now,
they're out there doing
meaningful things,
but they're only driving
in small scenarios
where they have perfect
maps, and they haven't
solved the whole problem.
So it's a perfect example of
how the robots are at a point
today where they can
do meaningful work.
They can make an impact
on people's lives,
but there's still
really hard set
of problems waiting
around the corner
to feel that these
things are a reality.
Thank you, Russ.
So please join the conversation.
We have a first question.
Would you like to
introduce yourself, and--
Yeah.
Hi.
I'm Alex.
Programmer from Brazil.
Thanks for creating
Inspirational Talks.
And little bit louder.
Alex, programmer in Brazil.
My question is around--
so 40% of us have access to the
internet after all this time.
And we're talking
about robots, and I've
read that most of the data
going around internet,
it's not human
generated any more.
So maybe you guys
can comment a bit
about the internet of things and
how if robots aren't internet
would impact or maybe even
overlap the human axis to it.
I'll take the first crack,
then I'll defer to Tim.
But there is actually a great
panel yesterday about robotics.
And Daniela brought hats.
So here you go, so yet get CSAIL
hat for asking the question.
So ask more questions.
You'll get hats.
It's a nice hat.
I had to work really
hard to get mine.
So there was a great panel
yesterday on cloud robotics.
So Google is talking about
cloud robotics and Ken Goldberg
from Berkeley.
So there's a dream in the field
that an individual robot can
only have so many experiences.
It takes time to have
experiences, get data.
We can have many robots out
there feeling all the time they
can share experience.
They can learn from each other.
They can map the world,
and it's much, much faster.
They can leverage the
compute power of the servers.
So cloud robotics is a thing.
It's happening, definitely.
And for humans too.
So a lot of the data
out there, people
are worried about
privacy because they
worried about the
data thing about them.
Well, actually I'm excited
about them being about me.
For me, the value of the
data about me is to me.
So if some marxing person
can makes some money
out of knowing something about
my detailed medical history,
they will get a certain
amount of limited value
out of knowing about
my demographics.
But if me, that's
data about me is
going to tell me where I'm
going to get a heart attack,
when I'm going to die,
where I'm going to die,
so not go there, then
that's more exciting.
So my favorite app at the moment
is the one that's runs on here
and checks my movements
just by listening.
The accelerant on my nose
gives me now back as far
as of October, I've got when
I'd been running and walking
sleeping and so including
where I've been,
a pretty good
journal of my life.
Adding to that, to my house.
It can tell me quite a lot
about when I was in the house,
about how I was moving and
turning the lights on and off,
adjusting the temperature.
We're getting to the point
where certainly, the house
gets smart enough to
know when I'm there.
Because after all, the list
knows when I'm getting close,
so now I can program
this took when
I get within it, certain
radius of the house,
a couple of miles,
to make sure it's
going to be warm enough for me.
So bit by bit,
there's lots of ways
in which I want
this world of data
to know a lot about
me because, dah, there
is so much stuff that
it could then do with it
that I wouldn't have to do.
And I can move on to
being more creative
and get the [INAUDIBLE].
So what I'm interested
in personally,
I'm using parallel
with myself as opposed
to worrying about who else is
using it for their own affairs.
Thanks.
So if I could just jump in.
I'm also very excited
about my data.
I'm also excited about how
I can improve the way I live
with my data, so take my data.
But the other side I wanted
to add to what you said,
Tim, is that we are now
developing technologies
to give people control over
who accesses the data and how.
And so why with these
new computational
approaches to
ensuring privacy, it
will be very easy
and very comfortable
for people to give
their data for whatever
causes and greater goods
and personal objectives
that we have, while
at the same time
to ensure that the
data is not used where
people feel uncomfortable.
And at CSAIL, a the labs is
we are starting a information
privacy project, which
is going to be proof
within a center within the map.
[INAUDIBLE] White
is heading, he's
a great one of
accountable systems,
putting accountable
systems into government
so the government can make
sure that people use or kind
of the way they used data.
Thank you for your question.
Let's take the next question.
Hello.
My name is today Amadeus
Ponticata, a really fascinating
panel.
And I have a question
about the future and some
of the limitations in hardware
where robotics examples we saw.
And there was some recent
examples of the swarming
and playing, a bit like a bird.
And it seems like there's
a lot of software, which
is trying to recreate
political systems
and teach you these neural
networks and machine learnings
and real cool stuff
like it was brain.
And so I think it
seems like people
have latched onto this idea
of natural and software.
What about hardware?
Where have you got to in terms
of biological and hardware?
There's some great famous
examples of mimicking hardware
to the point where your robot
doesn't work at all, where you
have every kinematic,
every joint, every link,
every motor is in the same place
as the biologic counterpart.
And you have a beautiful robot
that doesn't move [AUDIO OUT]..
Is that me?
So I think the inspiration--
so for instance,
if you can take the Wild Cat
video from Boston Dynamics,
it doesn't have every
link in the same place
that a cheetah robot
would have every link,
but its center of mass
moves surprisingly,
the ground reaction
forces are surprisingly
similar to what a cheetah runs.
So it's at that
level of abstraction
where we take the governing
principles of biology,
but skew them
towards the hardware
that we're good at building.
And so the cheetah
actually has more power
available at the joints
than a biological cheetah,
and we should be
able to do better
than that animals
in a lot of cases.
But we have to build the
hardware differently.
So it's not a perfect
kinematic, it's
by inspiration instead of
biomimicry is the trend.
Thank you very much.
Questions for Tim.
To protect freedom and
access to information,
would you recommend
it would be better
to apply this policy
and maybe technology
changes for our
existing internet,
or are there
fundamental changes that
could happen to the internet
that would change the playing
field all together and
create a way better internet?
Should we reinvent
a new internet?
Exactly.
No.
The internet is constantly--
Give it somebody else.
The internet is constantly
waiting to be reinvented.
But there has been
a huge problem
without every group trying to
get people to move on to IBD 6
from IBD 4, partly because
it was a step change.
While HTTP, if we couple being
continually, however, yeah,
there'll be quite a
step change in HTTP 2,
which is very much rethought
much more for real time
by any protocol.
But HTTP has been changing just
by the addition of new headers,
and it's been
tweaking sort of way.
It's really wanting to preserve
the existing structure.
To Britain, it's not going
to be from a dramatic change
in the protocols
where we're going
to get privacy or something.
Well, moving to lots of
encryption, but encryption
is largely there for you to be
using HTTPS, involving HTTP.
We should be using SSL.
I use BGP.
Hands up, anybody who uses
BGP encryption on an email?
A few.
Getting there.
The person does.
Matthew does.
And you don't.
Ask him about it afterwards.
So one of the
things we need to do
is to use the stuff, which
is already there like BGP.
Make it much more
easy for normal people
to use in the case of BGP,
particularly, BGP, P2P.
But in order to resist the--
for example, the government
is doing the wrong thing.
We have to work
on the government.
We have to put pressure on them.
We have to change the laws.
We have to establishing a
non-national constitution
bill of rights of internet.
And there's no quick
technical fix to the fact
that we have a bylaw.
Thank you.
Let's take the next question.
My name is Jeff, and
I'm dovetailing off
of that a little bit.
Considering that
it's taken 25 years
to get this current
state of infrastructure,
where do you see things coming
together so that we're not
relying on telephony.
There's a ability to get
PORT K, things like that.
And we rely on
telephone companies
to provide the service, with so
many municipalities not being
able to lay down the pipe
for fiber, et cetera.
So that's a very big question.
We leverage telephone
companies is really important,
at every layer in the internet
at the connectivity layer
and content layer that
independent markets and also
independent from
the device layer.
So I can buy a
device in one place.
I can completely
separate to choose
my internet connectivity,
choose which
movies I want to choose on.
So keeping those separate
and keeping each market
so it is a really competitive
market is important.
The last mile, which
you mentioned, will we
be stuck with--
where the town where I live,
the electricity company
is just going into
internet provision.
So because there
wasn't enough people,
there wasn't enough
competition in the phone
companies delivering
internet, I've lost my faith.
Other companies
can get internet.
Some large nameless internet
companies and search companies,
for example, even can get
into providing internet.
So I think it's really
important that we don't assume
that we have to rely on
the existing top telcos
for supplying our internet.
It's important
that the challenge
by all companies of
new business models
and new companies every State.
And you see that
changing over time?
Getting away from that?
The question is how do
you see that changing?
I think it may change in
lots of different ways,
and how it changes is up to us.
It's not clear how
it's going to be.
All right.
Thank you, Tim.
And next question.
Thank you so much.
Can you describe a
bit about the future
as far as the type
and nature of jobs
that will exist when
the future of robots
become well and
truly ubiquitous?
Could you speak on that a bit?
So I had to--
maybe Daniela is
also robotics, so
let me let her kill it first.
So we're very
excited about working
on the next generation
of robots that will
that will help people
in manufacturing,
and that will bring
manufacturing back to the US.
And we imagine a
world where workers
will be able to synthesize
the robots for any task using
computational tools and easy
interfaces, a kind of a robot
keep costs, if you
will, where instead
of printing your poster, you
will be printing your robot
to solve that particular
task on demand
at the time when
you need a task.
But the robot cannot be fully
in control of a factory.
People will still be in charge.
The robots will be
available to help people.
And in my dream, I would like
to see manufacturing environment
where we change from
design in the US
and fabricated in China
to design in the US,
customize at home in your
living room by yourself
and fabricate it locally.
I totally agree.
So in the first
robot revolution,
happened right around
the 1980s where
the PUMA robots came
out and revolutionized
factory robotics.
And if you look at the
automotive industry
just before that happened
and just after it happened,
we were producing basically
after 5 or 10 years,
we were producing
twice as many cars,
but we were also
employing 15% more people
to make those cars work.
So every time we've added
a huge technology leap,
it's been good for people.
It's been good for jobs.
The challenge is going to be
educating people so that they
can work with the robots.
And the next level of
technology leap, we
have to work right into
the education system.
We have to teach people computer
science and robotics when
they're young.
And the Dean Kamen,
the FIRST robotics team
is here at South by
Southwest, and I just
think this is so
important for the future
to make this transition happen.
Thank you for that question.
Next question.
Hi.
Good morning.
I have a follow-up
question on that,
and then a question
on internet policy.
So my question on the
previous question was,
do you see that as we start
introducing technology
like driverless cars--
Hold the mic.
As we start to
introduce technology
like driverless cars,
you can very much
see where the taxi industry
might become quickly obsolete
once that happens.
How do you see markets
where manual labor
or entry-level jobs will
be affected by robotics
and how that might change?
I think you're right.
I think that's a tough question.
I think people's jobs
will ultimately change.
But I think in the short
term, it's important for us
to embrace the
technology, make policies
so that people can explore this
technology, and educate people
so they can make the transition.
But I think some jobs
will inevitably change.
I think self-driving cars
are going to take time.
They're not as close as you
might feel watching YouTube.
But I hope that I'll be
reading a book next time when
I'm in a car in 20 years
instead of being stressed out
behind the wheel.
Can I just jump
in to re emphasize
that the jobs will not change
with the flip of a button.
They don't change instantly.
It will take some time,
and so the question
is, how do we retrain to go
along with this transition.
And hopefully, during
this transition,
the jobs will become more
exciting and more interesting
for all of us.
Just like what you experience
with the agriculture revolution
and with industrial revolution.
Excellent.
All of that, I think
would be worthwhile
thinking as a community, how
can we institute training
for people who are just entering
the job market on how they can
move on from a market that
perhaps is being replaced
by newer technology and help
them in their transition.
So that's a good question,
and here's the dream.
What if every high school
kid in this country
learned how to program
in high school.
Wouldn't that be cool?
Yes.
I'm a big proponent of that.
It's just as important as
reading and arithmetic.
Not just because we
need more programmers,
but because we need the people
who are lawyers and politicians
to know how to program so that
they can understand what's
possible with technology.
Exactly.
So in the 21st
century, I believe
that programming is as
important as reading, writing,
and calculating, doing math.
Yes.
The other question was--
We have some Trojans
in the audience.
It's very important
for lawyers as well,
but to have a foundation of
technology and as a manager
as well, I think it's really
important for managers
also to understand technology
and working with technology.
You should keep it.
All right.
So my follow-up question was--
Why don't you join
the back of the queue.
We have time.
We'll get to you again.
Hi.
Thank you very much
for the [INAUDIBLE]..
So to Professor Lo touched
on the subject a little bit
with the financial
data, but my question
is, do you think we
can actually make
a balance between censorship
and privacy and sometimes could
they conflict, and
who should do this?
Who should be the agency or
media to make this balance?
So I think that's a
very important question
that you raised, and I was
actually going to bring it up
when Tim was talking a
bit about the data that is
on the internet all about him.
I think that there's
a lot of benefits
to having all of
your data out there,
but your question really
is about potential costs.
And let me give you one
example, and then I'll
tell you what I think
you can do about it.
If I were an
insurance company, I
would love to get
that data that Tim
has on his app with
his accelerometer.
Because I'd like to
know how fast he drives.
I'd like to know where he goes.
I'd like to know what
his health condition is
because once I find out
all that information,
I may decide to
refuse to insure him.
Because he's not a good risk.
No way, buddy.
And this is the problem.
It's that when your
data is out there,
it can be used in ways
that are unanticipated.
And this is why I think Tim's
point about new legislation
is so critical.
We don't have legislation
to protect our privacy
and to prevent
the misuse of data
because, frankly, when the
founders of our country
were framing the
Constitution, they
didn't really understand the
notion of data and privacy.
So I think that with better
legislation-- and legislation
is going to have to
come from the people.
You're going to have to write
your congressman and say,
this is an important issue.
We want you to be at the
front of it and not in back.
I think that that's going to
be a critical part of what's
going to happen over
the next 5 to 10 years.
So you think someone
should be able to sensor
data and software because it
violates someone's privacy?
I think that censorship is
very different from preserving
privacy, and I think this has
to do with individual rights.
In other words,
you have the right
not to share your data
with me, but nobody
should have the right to
limit our free speech.
Those are two very
different things.
And I think that right
now the law does not
reflect that distinction, and we
need to have better legislation
to deal with those issues.
Thank you.
So thank you for that question.
We're officially
out of time, so let
me suggest that those of you
who haven't had their questions
answered, join us at the podium,
and before that, let's thank
the speakers one more time.
And also thank you for
those who were online.
[INAUDIBLE]